- Hi everyone, Sal Khan
here from Khan Academy.
Welcome to our Homeroom live stream.
Very excited about today's guest,
Superintendent Austin Beutner
from Los Angeles Unified School District.
So already, start thinking
about some questions
you might have for him and put
them in the message boards on Facebook
and YouTube or below this
video, or next to this video,
wherever it shows up and we'll try to get
to as many of those questions as we can.
But before we start
into that conversation,
I will give my standard reminders.
First of all,
that Khan Academy is not
for profit organization.
We can only exist with
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position
to do so, please go to
khanacademy.org/donate.
Also a special shout out
to several organizations
that have helped Khan
Academy really accelerate
what we're trying to do
during the COVID crisis.
As you can imagine,
a lot of folks are leaning
on us more than ever,
that's made our server costs go up,
we're trying to accelerate programs.
So special thanks to Bank of America,
Google.org,
AT&T, Fastly,
Novartis, and the many other
supporters of Khan Academy
over the years to allow
us what we're doing,
but we're still running into
dust, so we need your help.
Also one last announcement,
just reminder of our podcast.
So where we take
the interesting bits of
our conversations here
and I suspect today is gonna
be one of them and we put
into a podcast so that
you can actually listen
to the Homeroom while you
drive or do other things
without creating some
type of a safety hazard.
So definitely check out
Homeroom with Sal, the podcast,
wherever you find your podcasts.
So with that, I'm excited to introduce
Superintendent Austin Beutner.
Superintendent Beutner,
thanks for joining.
- Sal, thanks for having me.
I really appreciate you taking the time
to have this conversation.
- So maybe a good place to start
is just gonna lay the land.
You are in charge of the
second largest school district
in the country, highly complex
job under any circumstances,
but obviously under the last six
or seven months have
been especially unusual.
I just love kind of a background
of how have you handled this?
Like, what was it like last March, April,
as you were just, as the school closures
were starting to happen?
How have you navigated through the summer
and how are you thinking about it now?
- Great.
We're in the midst of a crisis
that none of us have ever seen before.
But if we remember where our North star,
the constellation North stars for us are,
which is student learning,
support for the families we serve
and making sure we take
care of our employees
who do those first two
things, we're gonna get there.
Now, as you mentioned,
Los Angeles is kind of big and unruly.
We have about 700,000 students,
more than 80% of them are from
families living in poverty,
75,000 employees spread
across 700 square miles.
So, much of what we need to
do we need to do in scale.
We need to be able to take an idea
and turn it into a reality and scale.
And what we've tried to do is respond
to those same set of priorities.
We immediately converted our school lunch
effort into a community
food relief effort.
We've now provided more
than 65 million meals
to hungry children and adults.
We're the largest school
relief effort in the country.
We've provided almost 10 million items
with that, whether they are books,
noise canceling headphones,
recreational sports materials,
baby supplies, with that, alongside that.
We made the effort to make
sure we could keep students
connected like this with
their school community,
so we bought computers.
We worked in March alongside
Apple to pull inventory
out of their stores to make sure
that we could get our
youngest learners iPads.
We worked with Verizon
to create a template
that we could buy very cheaply
to dramatically reduce
price for internet access
that we could provide to students
and their families for free.
For our students, many of
them live in the wrong side
of escaping digital divide.
We tend to think of it as that area
between South and North Dakota,
where there aren't cell towers,
but actually in many of
the committees we serve
families can't afford broadband.
So we set out to do that as
cost-effectively, as we could.
We set about training our
educators in what it means
to teach and engage online
and we've had three rounds of that.
We took all 35,000 through
a basic set of trainings.
We allowed another 15,000
to go for what I'll call
the masters in it and then we did
it again during the summer.
We did that all without missing
a day of school by the way.
To respond to learning
needs in the summer,
for the first time ever, we offered
summer school for every student
in our school district, everyone.
And we tried to take
some creative approaches
and you and I had this conversation before
about what student engagement
actually looks like
in this form of teaching and learning,
so we brought in
different set of partners.
James Cameron took some of
our high school students
on a voyager to the Titanic,
reading and literacy,
math and absolute engagements.
With Fender music, we
created virtual music classes
where Fender provided free guitars.
We had a thousand people
participate in the summer,
we kept it going to 2,000 more this fall.
The creators of "Despicable
Me" and "Secret Life of Pets"
worked with us on animation
and so students learned
to draw and tell stories.
And with Snapchat we created a book club.
And as much as I might
like recommend books
to our high schoolers,
Alicia Keys over Snapchat,
we reach students where they are.
And it was pretty exciting
to see the day we launched that.
Within moments, 500 of our students
had responded to her storytelling
about a book that she's
reading or had read,
and they could download it for free
out of some charitable funds we raised,
500 students in the
first just few minutes.
So we've tried to do things differently.
And I think I was a little
bit late, I apologize,
I was just coming from
taking a COVID test.
The next chapter for us is
we've set up a system to provide
testing for the COVID virus
and all the contact tracing
that go with us in schools,
because we think it has to
be part of a safe return
for all of the school
community to campuses.
So we have to do things different,
is part of the nature of it.
One of the things I hope we do talk
about is how we're learning
from this and how some
of what we're learning
will make us in the system better I think
when we get back to campuses,
but there's no substitute
for being in schools.
- Absolutely.
And maybe, you know,
there's so much of what
you just talked about.
Some very cool projects, I guess
reminding us that Los Angeles
is a fairly unique place.
But some of what you
mentioned, the lunch programs,
especially trying to
close the digital divide
or at least make it not
as much of an issue.
I'm curious, you know, we've been hearing,
talking to superintendents,
district officials
around the country that one,
I mean, that's not easy.
I am curious how you are
able to get the devices out.
I've read other places
outside of our conversations,
many tens of thousands
or even hundreds of thousands
of devices y'all pulled off.
But are you finding
that there's still kids
that are disengaged even after you get
the devices out there?
- Not easy to get devices,
so we looked ahead.
The old observation (indistinct)
when you see a toddler walk,
they bump into things 'cause
they're looking at their feet.
You need to look down
the road a little bit.
So we looked down the road and said, okay,
in February we started ordering devices.
We said, this could go this way,
they won't go bad, we'll figure it out.
In March--
- In February, that's actually worth,
I didn't remember anyone really talking
about school closures in February.
So y'all were thinking
of, y'all were doing
some (indistinct)
contingency planning, okay.
- Yeah, yeah, we're gonna look at that.
Now engagement takes many different forms.
So the first measure we have
is every student connected.
When we started in March,
we were short about 15 or 18% of the kids.
Within about four weeks 100% connected
'cause we said first,
they have to be part of
the school community.
Then we started to measure
what does connected mean?
Are they engaging in classes
through all of our
different tools and devices?
- How many devices did you
have to get out to do that?
I mean, just logistically,
that seems hard.
15% of 700,000 kids,
you're looking at over 100, 000 devices.
- More than that.
15% who when we
hadn't connected, but it's
actually more than that.
So it was hundreds of thousands of devices
and hundreds of thousands
of internet connections,
which is why again, we had to
reach out to Verizon and say,
can we do something different here?
Because the bespoke one by one connecting
wasn't gonna work, we
needed a wholesale system
to quickly get to that point.
And then we started
talking to our partners,
Khan Academy, amongst them to say,
how do we teach online?
What materials can we supplement with?
So whether it's Zoom or Nearpod
as connecting or communication technology
or different apps that may
be math or language focused,
we reached out to all of
them and said, we need more.
We need more from you,
we need to learn more,
we need to measure engagement,
we need for with the efficacy or usage.
Use case is for all of
these because for us,
technology has always been a supplement,
it was never the main event.
We took a quick inventory.
When our teachers were
going through the trainings
we were able to survey.
There were more than 400
different tools and technologies
and use in our classrooms,
that's too many.
As a supplement, great.
What is the core and the focus,
we had to figure out
where to place our bets,
which ones were most widely used,
what our feedback from our educators are.
And we continue to have working
groups where our teachers
are working alongside
the technology providers
to give them feedback,
so as the next generation
or the next need we have it's built
into the service they can provide for us.
So we measure connection,
we measure time utilization,
we measure assignments.
And one of the things that you
and I spoke when we first met
a long time ago now, how
you're able to tell us
just how much engagement
there was on your platform,
in the various parts of
it amongst our teachers.
Well, that's very useful for us
because we know there's a use case.
The customer's told us something
and we have a lot more available
to us in terms of a
digital footprint today,
how we use that wisely,
what the shortcomings are, how
that does or doesn't compare
to a classroom setting.
You know, those are questions,
we're still impacting some of them.
I mean, people say,
what's your attendance?
Well, we can measure physical attendance.
Okay, now we assume a lot of things.
We assume Sal's in a seat in the classroom
and therefore he must be paying attention
or learning something.
Well, that's not always the case.
The converse may be true
but Sal has not logged on.
Well, he might be reading a book,
might be working on a writing assignment.
And just because you
log on, I could turn off
and you could watch my
screen with my name,
I might be taking a
nap, one of my siblings
might be banging away
on the keyboard for me,
or I might be distracted at home
and dealing with other pressures.
So what we can learn digitally,
isn't always a signal and noise.
There's a lot of noise out
there, we have to figure out
where the signal is and
what's a value to us
as we work alongside our
teachers to get them the tools
they need and help them learn
how they can best use them.
- And what does that look like right now?
We're kind of a couple of weeks
into this new school year now,
how does digital learning
look in L.A. Unified?
Is it pretty consistent?
Are you seeing pockets of excellence,
places where you think you
could see some improvement?
- So we're 90, almost 99%
connected, kind of a start there.
'Cause we started a new school year
and so a high needs
population like we serve,
there's a lot of transiency,
a lot of new families,
families have moved.
We did a survey of families,
about a hundred thousand families,
three quarters of the families we serve
have had someone in the
household lose work due to COVID.
So the impact on families is enormous.
And so we started the school year
with mostly about being connected.
Are you safe and well?
Do we know each other?
'Cause that's the foundation for learning.
If you don't have that right,
you can't jump right into
the homework assignments,
it's not gonna work that way.
So we got to the 94% level.
The next is we look at,
are they participating,
students participating in
this type of engagement?
Is there a dynamic
participation engagement
between teachers and students?
We're also at pretty high levels there.
What's the daily attendance?
There's a new state standard (indistinct),
we comply with that and
how we measure attendance.
I was just out of middle
school this morning,
I said 99% attendance.
Kids are attending, they're part of it.
Now that engagement will
differ by community,
will differ by type of student.
We know that students who are struggling
the most are our young learners.
I haven't seen anyone yet show
me how you can teach someone
to read over a Zoom call.
Our English learners,
those students with
differences or disabilities,
those who might've been struggling
before school services were closed.
The challenge is greater now, for sure.
The challenge is greater
amongst our highest needs families.
So if you look at our enrollment pattern
compared to prior years,
you'd see we're up in
fourth and fifth grade,
we're up in high school,
we're down meaningfully in kindergarten.
So we had a bunch of educators
go into the community
and try and better understand
that and we heard back a couple of things.
We heard that families
struggling to get by
don't necessarily have
the support at home.
We heard some families have given up hope,
lost work and they've left,
which is a relatively expensive community
in which to live in
search of an opportunity.
And we've learned that
some families have said,
well, kindergarten, my
child's safe, they're in care,
whatever care might be and until students
are back in a school facility,
the imperative is not there
to enroll in California,
it's not law until the
child is six to be enrolled.
So we've seen those challenges.
So I could tell you kindergarten,
engagement's tougher unless
you've got an adult with you,
kids aren't logging on by themselves
or participating by themselves.
High schoolers, more capable
of learning independently.
I was with a young man this morning,
who's had perfect attendance
and is doing great
and he's a water polo player,
he's got it all put together,
but he's built that
foundation along the way.
And so our young learners,
English learners,
students with differences in disabilities,
we need them back in the classrooms
as soon as it's safe and appropriate.
- And what does the classroom
experience look like?
Is it a bit of whatever was happening
in a physical environment
has not been transplanted
to some combination of video conference
and then assignments on the
Khan Academy's of the world,
or is there a lot more variation?
- There's more variation.
I think, you know as well
not better than many,
that would be a mistake.
If we just tried to
replicate what we were doing,
it wouldn't work.
First of all, you'd have
eight hours Zoom days
and both students and teachers
would lose their minds from that.
That's not a good or
effective way to teach.
And so what we're seeing if,
the spring was that, you know,
try to carry on, keep students engaged,
but too late in the school
year to change much.
Summer was learning for students
and learning for our educators,
what can we do differently?
How do we use the time differently?
And the new school year
is more about that.
So the engagement piece
is focused on the interactive
and the technology
where information might be found
or a viewing of Khan Academy
might be done separate from that.
You find a little more
structure in the daily schedule,
which can help families,
can help our aides
and other non roster
classroom individuals,
teachers to make sure
they can all participate.
So a little more structured schedule.
And we're just getting into assessments.
We are assessing all students to see
where they are with low stakes.
Formative assessment of some sort,
let's say DIBELS, for instance,
in elementary for early readers.
And that's a challenge, you know, DIBELS
in a traditional first grade,
you can probably get done in one day,
assuming most of your students
are able to stay on task.
You don't test for, I'm sorry,
you don't prepare for it
as well as training for
it, so you want to see
where they are and meet
them where they are.
Now take DIBELS
to a Zoom where on any given day
one of your students may
struggle with the technology,
they may be distracted
at home, may not be quiet
or there might be
siblings or family members
who inadvertently give
them help or get away.
And the patience and
tolerance for young learners
to go through all of that,
that's a tough journey.
So we want that formative assessment
because students need the feedback,
their families need feedback
on where the work needs to be,
how to build on the strengths
and try to address some of the challenges.
But it's not so simple to
say, a DIBELS in the classroom
can go neatly and become a DIBELS online,
it's not that simple.
- Yeah and that's related to a question
I have here from Facebook.
Kids that care is part of their question.
Some parents at my school are pushing back
on the amount of screen
time and the youth,
I guess in this case, Canvas
is a learning platform,
have y'all done anything
to modify the curriculum?
What learning platform,
the learning platform,
maybe it's not as relevant,
but how are y'all,
are there some guidelines
on the amount of screen time
or is it still kind of learning
what families can handle
because now the parents are
kind of the teaching assistants?
- We sort of have, excuse me,
a minimum set of standards.
But it's gonna be different.
Without question, all of
this screen time limitations
in particular young learners have,
we have to be cognizant of that.
They can't...
Excuse me.
So we have a set of standards.
We leave flexibility
in the hands of the
educator who knows best.
Sal may wanna turn off
his camera, that's okay.
If that's where Sal is, we
still want Sal to participate.
He's still hearing, we
know he's participating,
so we try not to be too rigid.
And top down, we wanna hear
from the voice of the
educator in the classroom.
And you'll see, if you look at a schedule
you'll see time on, time off.
So the synchronous with
some asynchronous time
and back to synchronous,
as opposed to, we're
gonna have three hours
straight of synchronous.
You have an engaged audience I know,
but after three hours listening to us,
they would all be asleep
or they'd have turned off their computers.
And the same has gotta be recognized
both from a student perspective
and an educator perspective.
So yes, there has to be
boundaries around that.
And I think sometimes people wanna look
at the measure of synchronous time
and say more is better, less is worse.
Well, you're directionally right.
But there's no science
as you and I both know
on how much is too much
and so we're trying
to go into that carefully and recognize
the unique needs of students,
because some will do better in this form,
some will do better more independently.
And we want teachers to
have that flexibility to do
what they think is best
for their students.
- And what about in terms of the number
or the number of either subjects
or the coverage of standards?
You know, in a normal school year
you're covering oftentimes six,
in some cases, seven subjects
if you include things like PE and art,
and then obviously,
you're trying to cover,
end standards in a year in
an English or math class.
Is there a view to kind of free
up that a little bit to try
to say, okay, this is
the really the must haves
and then there's maybe some must to haves?
- Yeah, you have to do that online
and where that real task will come,
no pun intended is hybrid.
So I wanna talk about
hybrid and let's just unpack
what that is or isn't.
Hybrid exists because you can't get
everyone back in the same classroom.
It's not a choice anyone
will willingly make,
you have online or everybody back.
We all want everybody
back, but health protocols
won't let anybody back at the same time.
So you have to have smaller cohorts,
which means some will be in a classroom
and some will be somewhere
else accessed online.
Okay, so that gets us to hybrid.
Now think of the implication for
a master schedule and secondary complex
versus elementary.
Elementary teacher could
be with some students
in the morning and the
other half the students
in the afternoon.
And when the students
aren't with the teacher,
there could be an aid,
a playground supervisor,
there are other ways to
make sure that students
are with us all day in elementary
and the focus on the
core happens half day,
that's manageable.
And you can keep a small cohort together
for medical reasons.
Small meaning 12 students, teacher, aid,
they'll fit within a classroom safely.
If outbreak of a virus to occur,
you can isolate it to a
relatively small group
so it won't spread to the entire school,
that's elementary.
Let's go to the secondary
and more complex schedule,
typical in our high schools
or secondary schools to six,
six different classes.
So 12 plus a teacher, an aid,
go on to six, the math
will take you to two to 250
individuals that one person
could come in contact
with one or two degrees of separation
because you go from here.
You're not the same 12
all the way through.
So when we go back to
schools in a real hybrid, not
a call, let's say a medically sound hybrid
where we're keeping the cohorts small,
we're gonna have to look at
that master schedule and say,
what's the priority of
in-person instruction?
The rest may be at school instruction,
but actually provided by
an educator who's online
because we can't take you to sit
all six of your classes in-person,
because now we no longer
have a small cohort.
You've been around 250 students,
one of you or your teacher
were to have the virus
occur, all 250 gone.
That's not sound from health practices.
So we're looking at that
now and as we transition
at some point when it's safe
and appropriate in Los Angeles,
it's not yet when it is,
we're gonna have to look
at that complex master schedule
and to your original point,
there's the got to haves
and the foundation pieces
and then we will supplement
the others as best we can
and not all of the requirements
to be able to be met
in the same way we used to meet them,
but we're in the middle of pandemic.
And the point we look at and
say is, okay, online is online.
For almost all students,
being back in the classroom
is of benefit, okay?
If we can only offer you online
and in-person math and English,
that's better than online.
It will pale in comparison
to what we used to do six months ago,
when you could have French and music
and all of your electives
and everything else in-person as well.
But if we can't, we can't.
And so the health boundary
and the instructional boundary
have to coexist in the
same program for students.
- Now, it makes a ton of sense.
And I can only imagine, I mean,
scheduling is hard during a normal year.
I can't even imagine
that the contact tracing
and the cohort size, et cetera, et cetera.
I guess two questions in one,
and this is related to one from Susan
Garcia Dominguez.
"Hello Superintendent Beutner,
what rules need to be
rewritten for online learning?
I'll expand that a
little bit for, you know,
what has been the learning?
I mean, you mentioned there's
been learnings this year,
what do you think is the loss?
What are kind of your fears here,
that maybe the damage
that has already been done
and that might occur over
the coming six months or so?
And then what are silver
linings if anything
of this maybe from some
of what the rule rewriting
or whatever it might be??
- Yeah.
So I won't use the word rule
too much, but I think the loss
and the potential benefits, I guess.
The loss is a learning loss, for sure.
We spoke about already.
A lot of research on
what the summer slide is.
Now students have been in online learning,
but there's still been a slide for many.
That's
not hard to
assume that's the case,
hasn't been studied,
but let's assume that's the case.
And as each week and month goes
by, we're already at the six
month point where students
have been in classrooms.
So there will have been
learning loss for many.
There will be the social emotional side,
which is not getting enough attention.
It started in this country
as a health crisis,
is becoming an education crisis,
will become a mental health crisis
and so many of the
challenges we face in society
present themselves in schools.
So we're expecting and
planning for when students
are back in campuses that some
of the most foundational work
will need to be done around
the social emotional society
to allow educators to
move on and start to get
into the learning loss
and how we not only catch
up, but take students ahead.
Now we're trying to
intervene along the way,
we are doing one-on-one instruction
where we can do it safely outside,
we've set up online tutoring for free
to students and their families.
So we're trying to intervene where we can,
but the loss in learning,
the trauma and the challenge
when we go back to classrooms
is gonna be enormous.
I mentioned earlier, you
know, 75% of families
that have had someone whose work,
that's trauma in a household,
which may have already
been struggling to get by.
God forbid, a loss of life
or health and safety issue
with someone in the family due to COVID.
So that's coming, those
are all the deficits.
Now the challenge in the use of technology
can and I believe will
become of some benefit to us.
It will not supplant to replace
great in classroom learning,
but look at what we did with
Fender and say, it's an ant.
The classes with Fender are teacher led.
So our music teachers
are leading the classes.
We have Fender bringing
in their secret sauce,
bringing the Fender Play app
on top for students who want more
and one in one is about
five, it's amazing.
The work we do with the Alicia
Keys and Russell Westbrook
around Snapchat is a different way
'cause if we think about
the challenge in online
is also an opportunity.
Challenge in online is
students aren't with us,
they're not a captive audience.
So we've got to keep them engaged.
The opportunity is to
figure out how to do that.
Use different tools and technologies,
meet them where they are.
Alicia Keys is meeting them
right where they are there.
They're coming to her,
they're actually not coming
to class to meet Alicia Keys.
So if we can take some of
those skills and learnings
and bring them back with
us to the classroom,
you know, I hope the Alicia
Keys Snapchat book club
is around with us for a long, long time
as with the Fender music class
and some of the things we're doing.
So when we do get back to classrooms,
we'll know a lot more
about how we can make
the use of technology an important part
of the everyday experience
for all students
and we'll learn a lot more
about how we keep students
engaged, not just online,
but actually in a classroom setting.
- And you know, hopefully
maybe this time, next year,
things have close to
normal or back to normal,
how are you gonna be
viewing your job then?
Is it a lot of just, you know, well,
I don't wanna color your
answer too much, but is it,
there's the learning loss
you'll have to deal
with, what other things?
And there's the things
that you don't wanna lose potentially.
- Yeah.
I don't wanna make this
a money conversation
'cause I think it's more important
as a values conversation,
what we have to do to make sure
our students have that
opportunity to learn.
And as you know so well
learning's cumulative.
So those young learners who
aren't building the foundation
skills and literacy in
math and critical thinking
will have a lifetime of
consequences unless we get on that.
But there's a money issue looming too.
And for whatever set of reasons,
schools are the forgotten child
as part of the conversation
about how we recover from COVID.
The nation as a whole has risen
to the occasion to respond
to the needs of healthcare community.
That's great, we should.
No one should be without whatever
the appropriate treatment
is and those clinicians
on the front line should be supported.
The front lines are gonna
be in our classrooms.
And at the same time we are facing
the need to invest more,
to provide adult meals,
meals for adults because
they're hungry, we should.
To provide devices, internet access,
where we receive no
dedicated funding for that.
The cost of testing and tracing programs,
sanitizing and cleaning classrooms.
We changed the air filtration system
in every one of our schools,
80 million square feet of
buildings, replaced the filters.
We went from a MERV 8 to a MERV 13,
we just skipped all the
other MERVs in between.
And what a MERV 13 is, the filters,
the same membrane as an N95
mask, all that costs money.
And so as we're transitioning
from a healthcare crisis
to an education crisis
and the social emotional
(indistinct) of students
that come with that,
if there's not recovery funding,
schools are gonna be in a world of hurt.
Because municipal budgets, state budgets,
where most school funding in California,
it all comes from the state,
States are under a lot of budget pressure,
they've already said constant looming.
And if the federal government
or the state government
can't step up, at the same
time, we have to invest more.
We're looking at budget cuts
and the intersection of those two things,
it's not promising.
- Yeah.
Now, well, I wish there
was a rosier outlook,
but, I mean, that sounds like a very real
set of circumstances that
we're gonna have to struggle
with over the coming year.
Well, you know, these conversations
always go a lot faster than I expect.
And I know, I mean, we
just talked about it,
all that you have on your plate
and it's not an enviable position,
but it gives me comfort that folks
like yourself are leading the charge
in how we navigate this
very tough situation.
So thank you so much
Superintendent Beutner
for joining us today.
- Thank you. And thank you for having me
and thank you and your colleagues.
We found the work you're doing
at Khan Academy invaluable.
It's become a real, not just
option, but real necessity
for so many of our educators
to bring into the work.
So thank you for the work you do
and all your colleagues, I appreciate it.
- No, well it's our honor to
be able to help. Thank you.
Well, thank you everyone for
joining today's live stream,
I thought it was...
Being a superintendent is a
hard job in any circumstances,
especially of a school district,
the size of Los Angeles Unified
with 700,000 plus students.
You could only imagine
how hard it is in a time
like this when so much is changing.
So it's really heartening.
I know Superintendent Beutner
from before this conversation,
and I've always been
impressed with his work,
but not an easy situation to go in.
But I thought it was really valuable,
kind of understanding all of the levers.
So with that, thanks for joining today.
Some of you all might have
known through social media,
I have a, maybe they mentioned
it in yesterday's live stream,
I was sprinting with my son yesterday
and I have trouble with moderation
and I tore my right calf muscle,
which is not a pleasant, it
feels just like it sounds.
And it actually kind
of pops, it's horrible.
So that's why I wasn't
able to make it yesterday,
but I'm always willing to go
through the (indistinct) pain
to have these conversations.
So I'm doing all right now, much better.
I'm all loaded up on ibuprofen.
But anyway, thanks everyone
for joining and I look forward
to seeing you all for our
next Homeroom conversation.